a window on a worsening crisis in this
Paris intensive care unit it's a race
against time to save lives health care
workers are under strain hospitals are
overwhelmed the French militaries
airlifted some patients to other regions
and even neighbouring Germany and
Switzerland Spain hit another grim
milestone on Thursday as the number of
deaths there past 10,000 the country's
cut 900,000 jobs since it imposed strict
measures to fight the virus in hard-hit
northern Italy a deep cleans under way
by specialist teams from Russia Moscow
sent plane loads of aid to the country a
Kremlin PR exercise almost certainly but
one that's raised questions about the
--use ability to support member states
meanwhile in Moscow Red Square was
off-limits a surrounding streets were
sprayed clean president Putin's ordered
people to stay off work until the end of
April to control the spread brussels
responded to mounting pressure for help
on thursday with a proposal to borrow
more than a hundred billion dollars to
protect EU jobs the Commission chief
said it was time for an economic martial
plan for Europe many companies are now
left with no income and if we do nothing
they have to lay off their workers their
employees and this has as a consequence
when the engine will restart when the
world economy will restart they will not
have the skilled workforce they need to
take the offers so we will lose markets
and this will limit our recovery in the
UK no longer an EU member there's been a
surge in the number of people relying on
emergency food banks nine hundred and
fifty thousand people have applied for
welfare support ten times the average
over a two-week period this as British
Airways says it was suspending 80
percent of its workforce that's 32,000
cabin and ground
crew will now have most of their
salaries paid by the government more
than a quarter of all British firms have
now cut staff this is a crisis within a
crisis some of the biggest economies in
Europe are on their knees ill-prepared
for this unrelenting virus Nev Barker
al-jazeera